In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadeon from May 25th on which we commemorate our Holy Father,
Aldhelm, Bishop of Sherborn.
Saint Aldhelm of Momsbury.
There is a short mention in Bede, who was his contemporary, but most of our knowledge of
Aldhelm comes from the life written by Monk William of Momsbury.
He was born in about 639, when Kinnegill's, the first Christian king, ruled the West Saxons.
And Berenus, who had brought the faith to Wessex, was the Bishop at Dorchester.
At the age of 15 he was sent to the monastery at Momsbury to study under an Irish monk called
Madolf.
Although it had only been established for 20 years, it had already gained a reputation
for scholarship and a fairly extensive library.
In 661, Aldhelm took monastic vows and ten years later went to Canterbury, where the school
under two great scholars, Hadrian the Abbott and Theodore the Archbishop, attracted students
from every part of England.
He spent two years at Canterbury and would like to have made another visit, but illness prevented
him, and in 675 he was elected Abbott of Momsbury on the death of Madolf.
Aldhelm was then 35 years old and was to remain Abbott until his death in 709.
Madolf's church was a wooden structure, and Aldhelm replaced it with a great church
built in stone, celebrating its completion and dedication to Saint Peter and Paul, with
a poem of 21 lines.
He was an accomplished poet, and King Alfred's handbook tells the story of how, when the
congregation was thin at Momsbury, Aldhelm went out and stood at the bridge, entertaining
the people as minstrel, until he had lowered them back to worship in the church.
Besides the minster at Momsbury, Aldhelm established two other religious houses, St. Lawrence
at Bradford upon Avon, and St. John Baptist at Frohm, and there is still evidence of his
buildings at both places.
The ancient church of St. Martin is believed to have been built by Aldhelm, while he was
waiting to cross the continent on pilgrimage to Rome, and there is a small chapel dedicated
to him on the headland, which bears his name to the west of Swanage.
His visit to Rome was a great success, and he returned with a charger from the Pope for
his two monasteries at Momsbury and Frohm, exempting them from Episcopal jurisdiction.
Ina of Wessex and Ethelred of Mercia signed this document, guaranteeing peace to his foundations.
It is as a scholar that Aldhelm is best remembered, and among the writings that survive are his
treaties on the number seven, which he sent to his friend and fellow student Aldfrid, King
of Northumbria, a book of a hundred riddles and a dissertation on poetic meter.
His famous treaties, in praise of virginity, he addressed to Hildilada and her nuns at Barking.
Among whom was Kathberga, the wife of Aldfrid, who was to be the first abbess of Wimborn.
When Hedda, the west Saxon bishop, died in 705, the diocese was divided, with Daniel having
his seat at Winchester and St. Aldhelm becoming bishop of a new diocese with Sherborn as his
cathedral town. This new diocese incorporated the counties of Dorset and Somerset and part of
Devon, stretching to Comwell, with which Aldhelm had already had contact when he wrote a letter
to King Geraint, urging the British Church to conform to the Roman customs.
St. Aldhelm was only bishop for four years, during which he built a cathedral at Sherborn,
and continued to administer his monastic communities. He died at the age of 70 in the Church of
Doulting, and his friend Egwin, the bishop of Worcester, had a vision at the time of his death
and came post-haste to bury him. The funeral procession from Doulting to Momsbury was marked by
stone crosses every seven miles, and these were known as bishop stones. And we're still in
existence when William wrote. His tomb became a place of pilgrimage, and in 955 his body was translated
to a magnificent shrine, given by Ethel Wolf, the father of Alfred the Great. Alfred's grandson,
Athelstan, is buried by the side of his favorite saint, to whom he prayed before the battle of
Brennan-Brah, through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God,
of mercy on us and save us.